Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Emma Gon
Este es Zenón de Elea,
un antiguo filósofo griego
famoso por inventar
una serie de paradojas,
argumentos que parecen lógicos,
pero cuya conclusión
es absurda o contradictoria.
Durante más de 2000 años,
los enigmas alucinantes
de Zenón inspiraron
a matemáticos y filósofos
a comprender mejor
la naturaleza del infinito.
Uno de los problemas
más conocidos de Zenón
es la paradoja dicotómica,
que en griego antiguo significa
"la paradoja de cortar en dos".
Dice así:
Después de pasar
un largo día pensando,
Zenón decide caminar desde
su casa hacia el parque.
El aire fresco despeja su mente
y le ayuda a pensar mejor.
Para llegar al parque
primero tiene que llegar
a la mitad del camino al parque.
Esta porción de su viaje
lleva un tiempo finito.
Una vez que llega
a la mitad del camino
tiene que caminar
la mitad de la distancia.
De nuevo, esto lleva
un tiempo finito.
Una vez que llega allí,
tiene que caminar
la mitad de la distancia
que le queda,
lo cual lleva
un tiempo finito.
Esto ocurre
una y otra vez.
Puede verse que podemos
seguir así indefinidamente
dividiendo la distancia que queda
en distancias cada vez más pequeñas
cada uno requiere
un tiempo de recorrido.
Entonces, ¿cuánto tiempo tarda
Zenón para llegar al parque?
Bueno, para averiguarlo,
hay que sumar los tiempos
de cada una de las etapas del viaje.
El problema es que hay infinitas
etapas en el viaje.
Entonces, ¿no debería ser
infinito el tiempo total?
Este argumento, por cierto,
es completamente general.
Dice que viajar
de un lugar a otro lugar
debería llevar un tiempo infinito.
En otras palabras, dice que
el movimiento es imposible.
Esta conclusión
es claramente absurda
pero, ¿dónde está
el error de lógica?
Para resolver la paradoja
ayuda transformar la historia
en problema matemático.
Supongamos que la casa de Zenón
está a 1,6 km del parque
y que Zenón camina
a 1,6 km por hora.
El sentido común nos dice
que el tiempo de viaje
debería ser de una hora.
Pero veamos las cosas desde
el punto de vista de Zenón
y dividamos el viaje en etapas.
La primera parte del viaje
lleva media hora,
la siguiente lleva
un cuarto de hora,
la tercera lleva
un octavo de hora,
etc.
Sumando todos estos tiempos,
obtenemos una serie como esta.
"Ahora", podría decir Zenón,
"dado que hay infinitos términos
a la derecha de la ecuación,
y que cada término es finito,
la suma debería ser infinita, ¿no?"
Este es el problema
del argumento de Zenón.
Como ya se han dado cuenta
los matemáticos,
es posible sumar infinitos
términos de tamaño finito
y obtener una respuesta finita.
"¿Cómo?", se preguntarán.
Bien, pensémoslo así.
Empecemos con un cuadrado
cuya área es de un metro.
Ahora partamos
el cuadro por la mitad,
luego por la mitad,
y así siguiendo.
Conforme lo hacemos
sigamos la pista
de las áreas de las partes.
La primera porción tiene dos partes,
cada una con un área de 1/2.
La siguiente porción divide
una de ellas por la mitad,
y así.
Pero, no importa cuántas veces
cortemos las cajas,
la superficie total todavía es la suma
de las áreas de todas las etapas.
Ahora podemos ver por qué
elegimos esta forma particular
de cortar el cuadrado.
Obtuvimos la misma serie infinita
que tuvimos en el tiempo
del viaje de Zenón.
Conforme construimos
más y más piezas azules,
para usar jerga matemática,
conforme tomamos el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito,
todo el cuadrado
se cubre de azul.
Pero el área del cuadrado
es una unidad,
por eso la suma infinita
debe dar 1.
Volviendo al viaje de Zenón,
ahora podemos ver cómo
se resuelve la paradoja.
No sólo la serie infinita da
un número finito como respuesta
sino que el resultado es el mismo
que indica el sentido común.
El viaje de Zenón lleva una hora.